♪ ♪ ♪
- Delphine, voudrais-tu mettre
les napperons, s'il te plaît?
- C'est une famille recomposée,
celle de Christian, père
de deux en e e e et Marion,
qui est enceinte de son premier.
Il est ingénieur;
elle, nutritionniste.
Ils touchent de bons salaire
mais ça ne les empêche pas de
sursauter, depuis quelque temps,
quand ils paient leurs factures.
- Ouais, la viande rouge,
particulièrement, poulet, porc.
MARION CHAMPAGNE-CLICHE,
nutritionniste
- Les fruits, les légumes aussi.
Puis bon, avec mon travail
de nutritionniste, il faut
dire qu'il y a une certaine
part de l'alimentation qui
s s s s fruits et légumes,
donc c'est sûr que ça paraît
sur la facture, c'est certain.
- Comment ça s'est passé,
la journée à l'é
- Hum!
CHRISTIAN ALLARD, ingénieur
- J'ai fait le plein il y a
deux semaines, puis ça coûtait
en haut de 100 $, t'sais,
c'est la première fois que
ça arrive. Là, ça frappe
quand même. Ça nous empê
pas de vivre, mais c'est
quelque chose qui vient...
- Bien, c'est un... c'est
un coût supplémentaire qui
vient peser dansncncncncnce.
- On dépense
beaucoup en épicerie.
- Marion et Christian
surveillent leur budget de près.
Ils ont noté que leurs dépense
d'épicerie ont grimpé
de 21 % en octobre,
comparativement à l'an dernier.
Leur note de chauffage
au gaz a monté de 14 %.
C'est l'achat de carburant
pour la voiture qui
a connu la hausse la plus
spectaculaire, soit 60 %.
Et leur budget de loisirs
a aussi monté en flèche.
LUC VALLÉE, économiste
- On ressort de la pandémie
avec une forte demande, ça crée
des problèmes de congestion,ça s
d'augmentation des prix
de l'énergie, donc ça,
ça se répercute sur
les coûts des producteurs,
ûûûûûûts de livraison
aux magasins où vous allez
acheter vos bien, et donc,
évidemment, c'est normal
que ça vienne affecter
les prixenenenenenentation.
- Selon cet expert, d'autres
facteurs inflationnistes
s'ajoutent à la pandémie
pour ce qui est,
en particulier, du p
- Non seulement il y a
une retenue de l'offre
artificielle du côté de l'OPEP,
mais il y a aussi une baisse de
l'offre naturelle qui se fait
par le peu d'investissements
dans le secteur pétrolier.
Tant que la demande de pétrole,
elle, ne suivra pas à la baisse
parce que les consommateurs
vont dire : "Bien, j'en consomme
moins, du pétrole, je consomme
plus d'énergies alternatives",
bien, les pressions à la hausse
sur les prix vont continuerdans.
- Le coût de la vie augmente,
donc vers quoi est-ce
qu'on s'engage pour
notre futur financier?
'i'i'i'i'i'i'il n'y a personne
qui a une boule de cristal pour
déterminer si... ça va continuer
à augmenter de cette façon-là.
- OK, on commence...
- Avecrororororororochaine
d'un nouveau membre dans
la famille, Marion et Christian
avaient prévu déménager
dans une maison plus grande.
Leur projet es
en veilleuse.
- Au lieu de déménager tout de
suite, on a dit : bon, bien...
- Attendons de voir.
- On va réaménager la
en haut d'une des deux filles
et on va mettre les deux filles
ensemble, pour pouvoir faire
une chambre de bébé.
- Tout à coup...
la COVID empire!
- L'explosion des prix
en immobilier, les prix
de construction, aussi,
a teinté cette décision-là.
S'il n'y avait pas eu
cette explosion-là, on aurait
probablement déjà entamé
le projet de construction.
Je pense que l'impact le plussit
ça, c'est vraiment l'inconnu.
On voit que tout ça se passe,
on voit, d'une façon un peu
insidieuse, l'augmentationépépé.
- Pour faire l'analogie
du pont Champlain, là,
il y a du trafic sur le pont
Champlain, il y a congestion.
Esononononononononongestion-là
est permanente ou est-ce
qu'après que... la remorque
est venue chercher la voiture
qui a eu un accident,
les conditions
C'est un peu la même chose ici;
une fois qu'on va avoir réglé
le problème d'approvisionnement,
surtout de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement mond
au moins, le problème de
congestion qui, probablement,
est une des grandes composantes
qui contribuent à l'augmentation
de l'inflation aujourd'hui
va être réglé, d'après moi,
d'ici la fin de l'année 2022.
- sesesesesesesesesese récente
démontre que le nombre de
personnes qui ont recours aux
banques alimentaires a augmenté
de plus de 20 % en 2021,
comparativement à
Cela inclut des familles
considérées comme faisant
partie de la classe moyenne.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Monsieur le président,
je veux vous dire qu'on regarde
actuellement des moyens
pour aider les Québécois qui
n'ont pas eu les augmentations
de salaire en conséquence,
pour les aider à faire face
à cette augmentation énorme
du coût de la vie, entre autres
r r r r r r r r r r de l'épicere
puis du logement.
- Allô!
- Alors...
- Le mini-budget à venir
devrait rerererererererereres
d'aide publique pour faire
face à cette inflation.
Le couple de Gatineau
a quelques idées pour
le premier minis
- L'accès aux services de garde
est primordial. Les familles qui
ont deux salaires ne peuvent pas
nécessairement se permettre
de tomber à un salaire
qu'elles n'ont pas de place
pour leur enfant en garderie.
- Même si ça veut dire
de ramener une certaine
subvention additionnelle
pour les gens qui ont
un salaire plus aisé,
moi, t'sais, personnellement,
ça ne me dérangerait pas
de payer un petit peu plus.- -Çe
réfléchir à l'option d'avoir
un programme de repas dans
les écoles ou un programme
de collations dans les écoles,tt
financier aux parents dans
l'achat de la nourriture.